first four points that the Sheik
mentioned in relation to uh visiting
because that's what we see at the
beginning of the Hadith the messenger
ofam visiting the sick person the sick
person now before we continue I want to
mention a pertinent point which is that
the messenger of Allah he didn't mention
anywhere in his guidance he didn't make
a distinction with any diseases or
illnesses illnesses are of VAR types
people used to have fevers people used
to have zukam which is like a type of
cold or a you know similar to a cold or
a flu all types of illnesses the
companions used to have but there wasn't
any distinction made between visit that
one and not that one because this is a
non-contagious disease and that's a
contagious disease so you shouldn't
visit we don't find any of this in the
guidance of the messenger of Allah
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and this is
why some of the scholars uh from them uh
in the past and likewise in the present
for
example in his time there used to be
plagues in the time in in in Egypt many
many waves of plagues and so discussions
would happen between the scholars as to
well what happens about visiting the
sick then what do we do about visiting
the one who's got the plague in a
household so some jurists were of the
view were of the opinion that you know
if if two doctors say that this is going
to harm him then the person shouldn't
visit you shouldn't visit because they
might harm you so what I haar said that
that which we know from actual
experience is
that the family of the one sick with the
plague are the ones who mix most
intimately with the sick person they are
sleeping by his side or her side they
are attending to his wounds they are
feeding him drinking you giving him
drink they are you know uh cleaning you
know the the the the wounds and so on so
forth breathing the same air as him in
the same room as him eating the same
food with him and the majority
they none of them are basically affected
yet they mix most intimately with the
person with the plague so if that's the
case then how can you say that someone
who comes and sits to visit to fulfill
the right of a Muslim and sits there for
2 minutes 3 minutes 5 minutes asks how
he is you know uh gives him good words
and then leaves how can you say that
person has something to fear when the
people most intimately mixing with
him don't don't ever get get the plague
because in in the household it was it
would only be one or two people that
would really get the plague and most
people wouldn't actually get the plague
so how so what haar said is that the
doctors who give this testimony their
test testimony is to be rejected because
it just opposes factual reality and
likewise even contemporary Scholars they
say the same thing for example Muhammad
Aman Al
Jami when he's speaking about the same
issue he says look we we know that we we
wash the leper and we shroud the leper
and this is what people have been doing
throughout history and no one has caught
leprosy just by you know washing the
leper and you know doing the janaz
whatever we this is not really known so
so
um so the reason why we mention this is
because it's to do with the issue of
visiting the sick and also because it's
it's pertinent to mention because in the
modern era in the Contemporary era there
is a big there is a big uh tribulation
which is being driven by the people of
disbelief where they use this issue of
contagion to stoke fear and to
exaggerate in this issue to make people
fearful when you shouldn't be fearful of
anything right in terms of like the flu
and this and whatever th this is all
um this has a connection to issues of
belief it has a connection to issues of
behavior and we are people
ofed and you
know what whatever whatever means that
we take or whatever behave behaviors
that we exhibit they have to be based
upon facts and they have to be based
upon true and real causes right now when
they say there's the bird flu for
example or there's the cow flu or
there's the bat flu or whatever all
that's happening is that in farms these
birds are kept in unnatural
conditions they are fed the wrong things
they are kept closely packed so that
when they you know when when they uh the
feces or the or the uran or whatever it
has high levels of ammonia ammonia right
so you're present in an environment
where the animals are having to you know
take in ammonia then the food is not
good because it's industrial farming on
a big scale then they probably give
given medications or antibiotics to to
to prevent the illness because of the
environmental conditions so obviously
some of them are going to like become
ill right they've become ill because of
the sit the environmental situation
which is unnatural so when that happens
the
body
reacts by
executing a program or a or a what we
what we what what we call it's like a a
correction mechanism which we can call a
homeostatic correction right the body is
trying to correct Itself by by you know
running this program program that will
eliminate the toxins or eliminate any
tissues that have been damaged or any
Linings that have been damaged so it it
ruins this process where there's like a
fever and then there's a mucus and then
and so the body the whole body like the
fever the whole fever is
working uh to to to mobilize the whole
body to execute this program to bring
the body back to normality right so some
of the birds will undergo that process
just like as humans when it comes to
Autumn when it comes to Winter right
there's there's lack of sunlight and you
know there cold and whatever some of us
might undergo the same thing this
happens to all biological like organisms
or animals right so then the body starts
expelling the material some of this
material
dead tissues dead cells genetic
fragments different proteins different
vesicles they're coming out of the body
the body's expelling them and it's
coming from within the
body right there is no darwinian virus
there's there's no virus out there
that's coming invading and making you
ill this this doesn't exist this doesn't
exist and I've said this before and I'll
say it again that I say this in the same
way that I say that there's no such
science in Islam that is called that whe
of the attributes this doesn't exist
this is this is philosophy this is
foreign it's from outside and it's being
brought into and made it's like a pseudo
science doesn't
exist of the because you might be so
therefore we have to establish by saying
hand
means and means no this doesn't exist we
know it doesn't exist why do we know it
doesn't exist because we have the
historical record we've done the
research and we know what the S were
upon we know this is a foreign uh you
know invention we know that for absolute
certainty it doesn't exist so I say in
the same way the idea of the pathogenic
darwinian virus it doesn't exist and
you're not going to you're not going to
rebut this you're not going to refute
this just like there going to be people
who going to come and say no no there is
that wheel because how come so is alaki
wrong
then was Al Baki like you know was he
wrong for making
just like people in Islamic Sciences are
going to come along and try to argue
back with you with what they think is
evidence in the same way in the worldly
science is going to they're going to be
people likewise coming back to you and
arguing back against you trying to
trying to trying to establish falsehood
what what is blatant falsehood right so
this is not going to happen you're not
going to prove that there is a p by by
the mechanism of the scientific method
you want not going to you're not going
to prove it it's not going to happen
because it's all fraud and so the signs
this will not change if you invoke any
he health health authority of any Muslim
Nation or any rulers or any whatever is
not going to change right this fact
won't it's not going to change because
it comes down to actual evidence through
the actual scientific method just like
in Islamic Sciences there's a standard
of proof is there not right if you want
to prove something Quran Sunnah of the
salf
and then obviously sound usage of of the
Arabic language and correct inter
interpret of the Quran and we are
objectively able right if somebody comes
with an opinion or a statement we are
objectively able to see okay is this
true is this false does it agree with
the Quran of the why because we have we
have an objective Criterion for that
just like for example in the science of
Hadith in the science of Hadith is there
not a science by which we can say
this report is authentic this report is
inauthentic why why it has to be a
connected chain of trustworthy truthful
reliable people who must be known by
name there mustn't be any uh you know
hidden uh defects and it mustn't oppose
what is already firmly established
through other narrations right this is
an objective science by which we which
we can apply objectively to any report
any CH of generation and
say whatever there's an object
uh science there likewise in the worldly
Sciences there is an actual scientific
method that we use to establish cause
effect relationships all right and the
method is well known there has to be a
dependent variable an independent
variable you make a hypothesis there's
the null hypothesis then there's the
alternative hypothesis you have to do
experiments to confirm or reject one or
the other and then upon that you then
continue moving forward forward forward
until you understand the phenomenon
really really well right if a science is
not based upon if if the theoretical
foundations are not based upon that
process that's not a science it's not it
can't it can't be you know it's not it's
not an actual science right so the whole
of what they call virology and Daran
viruses it's it's all merged with
Evolution right these are all lies when
they tell you that it's mutating and
it's this and whatever there's no these
are stories
it's not true as much as you might want
to believe it and you're going to have
all medical people coming now and you
know just like you're going to get an
coming right bringing these are shat
they're not they're not evidences they
shat right and a Sufi coming trying to
prove the
M with not
evidences right it it doesn't count as
evidence what he's bringing what he's
bringing a misinterpretations
Fabrications weak Hadith you know views
of Scholars even views of Scholars the
same thing happens in science same thing
happens in science exactly the same
thing if it can happen in relation to
what Allah
revealed it can happen in relation to
what Allah created right just that just
as there is misinterpretation of what
Allah revealed there is
misinterpretation of what Allah created
in The Sciences of the people of
disbelief right so uh then we can go I
don't want to Del too much much on this
want to move on
but there are so many there are so many
uh elements to this what I'm telling you
that even after the first World War uh
there were extensive hundreds and
hundreds of experiments done in order to
tr try to transmit the flu from sick
patients in the military in the Navy to
healthy patients so they would have like
10 beds in a hall all the sick people
they bring uh dozens of people like you
you sit with this one you speak to him a
Close Quarters you breathe what he
breathes and move to the second one then
the third one then the fourth one then
the fifth one do it for 10 minutes each
all the way around right then next stage
they would ask the guy to open the mouth
and the sick person would cough
straighten his mouth they'd go along
like that then what they would do is
they would take the mucus from the sick
people the bronchial fluid and whatever
put it in the like spray thing and then
spray in the back of the throat of the
healthy people they try that then they
would try even taking blood sample from
the
uh the sick people with the so-called
Spanish flu then inject the healthy
people and they could not make those
people ill it just couldn't make them
couldn't make them
ill right and there is a book which has
been released recently it's called can
you catch a cold can you catch a cold
you might want to buy if you're in in
medicine or in the Science Background
can you catch a cold put on put on
Amazon this book brings
all every sing single experiment done
over the past 150 200
years trying to transmit the common Cod
of the
flu right every single experiment and it
discusses this issue and you can't you
can't transmit the cold or the flu no
matter you know there is some
intricacies to the issue which you need
to understand but it's not it's not a
transmissible it it doesn't it's not
transmissible right so
the reason why I say this is because we
know that right now there's the big push
like the bird flu is happening and uh at
the moment it's like in animals and cows
it's in birds and cows because they want
to kill all the chickens they want to
kill all the cows uh to destroy the
farmers because the big money is buying
up the Farmland they're buying the
Farmland right and they want to destroy
farmers in Europe in America uh all all
in the Western World this is what they
are basically doing they're trying to
consolidate the wealth the power
the land the property and whatever so
these rich and powerful people have
schemes they have schemes by which they
achieve this right and so at the moment
it's going to be because the same people
are trying to create synthetic lab grown
meat as you very well know right growing
stakes in the creating companies that
where they're going to profit hugely
from growing synthetic meat and likewise
with dairy and likewise you know so
as Muslims we should never be deceived
by the people of disbelief and their
machinations right and yes we can be we
can be misled once we can we can fall
into this deception once maybe twice
even maybe but a Believer is not you
know he not stung from the same hole
twice and so this time around as you see
all the it's it's it's starting now it's
rolling the bird flu when it comes to
Autumn it's going to now then they're
going to start saying oh it's it's
jumped from humans to to it's jumped
from uh Birds to to humans now now this
human to human transmission now start
testing it so when they start testing
the tests are fraudulent the tests only
detecting your own genetic material the
tests are utterly
fraudulent right it the test cannot tell
you anything so so as soon as you start
testing that's when all the cases are
going to appear because the tests
generate the cases they don't detect the
cases they generate the cases do you
understand right so don't fall for this
second time and the first time we can be
excused but the second time we can't
fall for this nonsense because now this
is to do with like this comes to do
withans uh false exaggerated fear
unwarranted fear doing things which are
not even not warranted they're not even
from the means you know making you
fearful of other people for absolutely
no reason stay six feet from that one
stay you know six from that one don't
mix with this this is all baseless
fearmongering right this now has an
impact upon upon your Creed and your on
on your
behavior right and so you must follow
the evidence